from the same guy for the my holy [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] wearing this [ __ ] all the
time
[Music]
probably
here
[Applause]
this was last Monday morning in your
life oh good Saturday not a whole lot of
a daily be action we can throw is going
to be a little tricky to earn I'd pump
it out of quick like 15 20 minute
workout happy birthday max went to the
birthday party with the jurors that was
fun
she's been reading all the comments
engaging very hip hop behind a week I
would do this man I've been looking
forward to it like if I could do what
you did I'd be the [ __ ] I'd be real
[ __ ] famous because I really
understand distribution hope that my
whole thing's gone done my dad's gonna
be real happy thank you talk down but
now my god and he look great it's great
put up 165 days of songs for us in his
life he would win real pleasure my man
sir how are you
there's no good man this was fun
just grinding just a lot going on such
an interesting thing when I was filming
up planet of the apps a couple weeks ago
or in December will.i.am was trying to
razz me and get this kid to go on his
team because plenty apps is a little bit
more like The Voice if the shark tank
meets The Voice for apps so we'll try to
get people to go on our team so we can
mentor them to get in front of DC and so
he's trying to get this one app to uh my
arms
okay so like this okay so should I get
this one app kid to go with him and he
goes look and we're talking about
marketing and getting people ability app
because look if you want to if you want
to go with marketing if you've been
marketing is what's going to kill it for
your app then you got to go Gary B so
that's marketer I've ever seen
smarter new world but if you care about
culture then you've got out of so
[ __ ] pen so the [ __ ]
will.i.am here's a great move I jumped
in them like look if you like coach your
marketing so much well why are your
headphone companies working with my
company vaynermedia so a razzing but
what's been interesting over the last
two to four weeks looking at mean
culture looking at Instagram influencers
looking at Facebook video looking at a
hip-hop emerging talent you know for the
Flippa
and so like Hollywood and Sobhan some
kids I'm hanging out with just really
looking at the business landscape why
commercials aren't working there's this
incredible moment right now I feel like
I'm penetrating this like culture
forcefield and I can see it all the
pieces coming together and and the way
that will cause the culture I call it
attention they treating attention
attention arbitrage these subcultures
during Fitness influencers hip hop
influencers cartoon influencers gamers
on Twitch
you know the entrepreneur hackers you
know there's just this interesting
convoluted matrix that is moving every
day musically snapchat Instagram you
know Facebook doing much more 22:30 than
people think you know stuff like that
really fascinating I feel like I'm in it
I feel like I blew a headed a minute
right now spring/summer the show comes
out just feel like 2017 is going to be a
beast what if everybody real quick we're
going to start using clipped from a year
ago things that we filmed in daily be
that happened a year ago as contact
points or make fun of my predictions
that were wrong or just daily be
classics that add a little spice
especially a weekend of soda so okay
check it
so daily basis licenses clacking dealer
did you up on my hand on that pack Dan
Grossman although I think yeah your
heart and I should have some record
critical my father's arrangement this is
awesome you can take the musician you
can take service attitude in
entrepreneurship as looking about
everybody watching this right now
it needs the Americans in believe people
don't think entrepreneurship and skill
right they don't think they can be
LeBron or being you know Nine Inch Nails
or Lisa V ascent but everybody looks at
me and says I can do that yeah they
don't understand that it's a talent by
the way the other thing that it's more
practical to actually recognize them a
talent and looks like they think
Alejandra I'm the best yeah then being
at 68 is actually quite financially and
Happiness worthy whereas if you look at
the Brawn and he's a hundred being a 68
means that like you'll spend a lot of
time in rec league like like it is a
stiffener is right it costs you money to
try to be a 68 musician it takes 15,000
demo you have an overhead like you can't
pay rent this thing being a 60 even for
people that clearly understand that
they're not meaning how is wise it's
actually quite practical to be a 68
[Music]
probably